[Applause]
thank you
happy Thursday everyone so is it really
so great to have presidential debates
yeah it's time to review
the feudal rally rally in Simi Valley
yeah as you can see in the lower right
hand corner of your screen it's been 23
hours since the second GOP Presidential
debate
no one's ever done that before
and much like vivek's hairline my
migraine is finally receding
the debate was held at the Ronald Reagan
Presidential Library a reminder of an
era when a president leaving office at
the age of 78 was considered too old and
a reminder that it is still legal to
park a jet in a library
excuse me ma'am where can I find the
classic literature section right behind
the 747.
okay so in case you missed it let's get
right to the highlights here are all the
best parts
how would you as president protect
from a foreign government like China how
do you think about dealing with the root
causes of crime especially this
revolving door of the criminals they
just get out and come back and commit
another crime what is your mathematical
path
Governor DeSantis in order to try to
beat president Trump who has a
commanding and enduring lead in this
race
yeah
that lady's pretty good
she was the only moderator I could
understand without a struggle somebody
should give her a job sitting next to an
incredibly handsome genius every day at
five o'clock
and also Jesse Waters
anyway here's a little known fact that I
just made up debate is actually a Latin
word meaning everybody talking at once
thank you for speaking while I'm
interrupting
gentlemen you'll have your turn one of
the challenges
in China everybody knows that let's have
a policy debate what's going on um
yeah that happened a lot and I mean a
lot
[Music]
totally wrong
all those voices I felt like I was
inside geraldo's brain
to Dana's fellow moderator Ilya Calderon
but damn and I'm not talking about her
accent although she does make Salma
Hayek sound like Queen Elizabeth
struggled I struggled with her but look
If you hired me to moderate a Spanish
language debate I wouldn't do a very
good job either but at least I wouldn't
fill up the airwaves with a bunch of
liberal cliches or as they say in
Spanish
you have said slaves develop skills in
spite of slavery not because of it but
many are still hurt what is your message
to them would you work with Congress to
reach a permanent solution for dreamers
what is your specific plan to curb gun
violence violence against lgbtq plus
people is on the rise and intensifying
how would you protect this community
from violent attacks
so those questions insulted me because
we've regularly challenged those phony
talking points every day and yet here we
pretend they're agreed upon truths at
this debate too bad the candidates let
them fly because those questions which
oddly had no follow-up from her could
have been written by Keith olberman if
he could still write
she Amplified a smear about DeSantis she
blamed Americans for the fentanyl
flooding the southern border she asked
Mike Pence what he would do to stop
violence against lgbtq plus people
sorry guys this is a republican debate
if I want my intelligence insulted I'll
talk to Brian Kilmeade
but that's Univision it's not Fox News
so that's a good call RNC well done
thankfully Pence was good for a few dad
jokes
my wife isn't a member of the teachers
union but I got to admit I
I've been sleeping with a teacher for 38
years
for 12 years although it seemed longer
yeah he made Ronald Reagan Library sound
like an actual Library
the guy's stiffer than Nancy Pelosi's
eyebrows
if I wanted horribly delivered bad jokes
Seth Meyers is back Monday they don't
even know him
like why did he bring up this stranger
the Santa seems to have pulled ahead
however simply by not his pants
low bar and near the end thankfully he
was able to articulate something Beyond
a robotic smile and stiff arm movements
because up to that point I was waiting
for Dorothy from The Wizard of Oz to oil
his elbows
the vague he was weird he went from the
insult pirate of the last debate to hey
you guys are awesome now and every time
somebody insulted him his hair grew a
little higher by The End by the end Air
Traffic Control at LAX kept telling him
to duck
but he did make good points about Mental
Health social media trans and kids and
he did have the last word as the debate
crumbled Into The Ether I'd say Nikki
Haley came off as shrill but at least
she nailed Tick-Tock even as they
advertised during the debate
you know you're being lied to when Tick
Tock suddenly pretends to be right wing
but there was one candidate who like
Hunter Biden on Father's day was absent
Donald Trump
Donald I know you're watching you're not
here tonight because you're afraid of
being on the stage and Defending Your
record you're ducking these things and
let me tell you what's going to happen
you keep
no one up here is going to call you
Donald Trump anymore we're gonna call
you Donald Duck
it's okay okay like a human bottle
opener that was a that was the worst
delivery I've seen since the octomom
gave birth
Trump wasn't there of course because
he's leading every poll and every attack
on him felt like a child getting back at
Daddy
but I would have heard these guys
answering the questions instead of
taunting the orange Menace so yeah the
clear winner of the debate Dana Perino
why isn't she running for president
Not only would she be the first female
president ever but she'd be the first
one to take the oath of office while
standing on six phone books
just think about all the extra room
they'd have in the white house we could
Airbnb it to pay down the debt but it
was hard to pick a winner because no one
shined I felt like a school bus driver
taking a group of noisy delinquents to
community service and you know what it's
not their fault either if the Advent of
podcasting taught us anything it set
this free-for-all debate structure is
deader than Joe Biden's frontal lobes
turns out you know every it turns
everyone into Look At Me potshot artist
instead of people explaining why they
should be president I felt gross
watching it but that could have been the
three pound cakes I ate who didn't feel
like slitting their wrists after that
quarrel over curtains
as the U.N ambassador you literally
bring it fifty thousand dollars on
curtains you got bad information first
of all no uh curtains do your homework
Tim because Obama bought those curves
did you send them back it's in there did
you send them back it's the state
department did you send them back you're
the one that works in Congress oh my God
you get it you hung them on your your
curtains they were there before I even
showed up at the residence
a fight over Burtons
does it matter who was right or wrong
[Music]
or wrong powerless to stop the noise
because the structure leaned into the
chaos instead of preventing it from now
on they should give the moderators
tasers that'll quiet things down they're
gonna use the potato gun on Christy but
carbs only make them stronger
but maybe it sucked because when you
compare debate structures to long-form
interviews where you learn a lot about
the candidates you know maybe it's time
to take this sort of spectacle out into
the woods and shoot it this is 2023 that
debate felt so 2015. we deserve better
like smaller debates between two
candidates one after the other it's
worth a shot one thing's for sure no
matter what you think about the GOP
candidates including the one who didn't
show up none of them are as bad as this
guy
yeah
[Music]
yeah we need a president who can stand
up for America or maybe one that can
just stand
his hair hasn't moved since hurricane
Sandy Fox News contributor Charlie hurts
is that his wallet or is he just happy
to see me shark tank star Kevin O'Leary
[Music]
as a former ring announcer we sometimes
ask her to empty my spit bucket out kick
host Charlie Arnold
and doctors often prescribe his act as a
sleep aid actor writer comedian Jamie
lissau
Charlie last night was a mess it was a
mess oh that charge oh sorry sorry we're
gonna try to clarify here I'll call you
Charlie too Charlie one
because you're a guy she's a girl that's
good yeah sexist right what did you make
of this uh well it's hard to top well
you're uh opening there I agree with all
of it
um and and I think your analysis the
format is dead is the problem and so
what you wind up with is all it becomes
a one-liner contest right and you have
all these people coming out with these
canned one-liners and they all suck yeah
and of course the best one-liner of the
night was the one and it wasn't even a a
canned one from Dana yeah where she asks
Mike Pence a question about is Obamacare
here to stay and he goes on this long
wandering explanation about how he's
opposed to mass shootings yeah and then
he gets the end of it and she goes so uh
are you saying that uh Obamacare is here
to stay and it was hysterical yeah but
then but then uh you know you know all
of them you know I I do think the debate
was clarifying uh none of these people
and I love these people who think that
oh what we need to do is we need to
winnow it down so it's one person if you
if if you can't beat Donald Trump and
he's not on the stage then widowing out
every everybody and having just one
person up against Donald Trump you're
still not going to beat it you're going
to get beaten worse and of course you
know you have Democrats who are all in
uh you know everybody talks about
democracy and how we need to protect it
and you have Democrats saying that you
know we want to protect democracy by
jailing Donald Trump so people can't
vote for him and now you have
Republicans who support Ron DeSantis who
are so upset because Rhonda Sanders
keeps screwing up these debates and
doesn't do well at them and they're like
oh everybody else needs to get out of
the race and it's like that's that's not
democracy and that's not going to help
it's not all right uh Kevin you're
Canadian and I apologize
are you embarrassed for us was it that
bad or I always have to shut up my other
passports so they don't get mad at me
also Irish also emirati come on throw me
a bone
here's my thing on this I'm trying to
think when I was listening to this again
can I sue you for making me watch it
twice in 24 hours I mean it was horrific
and you know I I've always said this I
can't make money with politics I make
money with policy show me something
about what you have and what you're
going to do that I can make some money
off right and I got none of that I just
got that whole squawking soup you
couldn't hear anything the one thing I
found interesting and I noticed when you
have a British accent like Stuart Varney
he can cut through something about that
British Vibe when everybody says oh it's
a British guy talking let's stop and
listen yeah that was interesting yeah it
was interesting I think
Wyoming you had uh British and you had
uh Spanish yeah I thought Doug burgum
actually switched some ideas about
energy and other things on policy and
that guy doesn't get enough air time but
but that's the problem he's a serious
guy yeah and this is no format I'd like
to hear more from him he's got your gun
serious eyebrows like I say he's like
the eyebrows are the best thing about
him he's like count chocula right
Charlie do you feel less optimistic or
more optimistic Charlie too I I feel
optimistic about the fact that I have
just more gratefulness for president
Trump I think we all owe him a big thank
you at this point because last night was
the second reminder of how unwatchable
and utterly unlikable the Republican
Party really is and the way that I see
it it's kind of like social media
because none of them could resist taking
Jabs at Trump last night right he
clearly is living rent-free inside of
all of their heads at all times yeah
even though they they like to deny that
it's like social media I'm sure everyone
here can relate you post something and
there are people that follow you and you
know that they hate you and they
constantly every time you post all they
do is leave really rude comments
underneath what you say all the time it
never fails but that's what it reminds
me of it's like Trump's the one posting
and these candidates are the ones that
are in the comments that no matter what
he says or does they just can't help and
then it gets even better because you
then see the people who are in the
comments Who start arguing among
themselves yes for days on end that's a
good idea like that that's what this is
here that's a good analogy that was a
debate that was just a bunch of
responses on X exactly Jamie I imagine
because you really don't have a life you
did watch the debate
I haven't heard people talk over each
other like that since um I remember when
I was getting married in my ex-wife's
family when they go hey speak now or
forever hold your peace
um ex-wife ex-wife because I say wife
I'm sorry I just figured everybody knows
um from being on the show I'm surprised
Christy is not better at debating
because he wins that one every night
where he's like should I eat the whole
gallon of ice cream
um
laughs
[Applause]
nice the scientist has got to work on
like just being more I've I've seen more
natural movement from members of the
Chuck E cheese band
[Laughter]
um that Tick-Tock thing I think they
should leave you know I like I like he's
been on the show he's a nice dude I
thought that was like a weird sort of
like are you something that has nothing
to do with anything yeah because we're
all kind of on I don't know some I'm on
Tick Tock it doesn't worry me I think
the whole they're gonna steal your
information if they want it is is what I
think that could be incorrect because
they go They're going to steal your
identity I'm like okay well I I don't
get laid and I can't get a mortgage
um
what like why don't you take it and let
me know how that goes
all right
or Jamie Jamie you have a girlfriend
I do I know I thought I doubt you I know
it was weird I felt like you were lying
and I was like he's not
that's how weird it is I don't know why
I said that we can edit that out later
so the lesson here is they really should
leave the one-liners to Jamie list out
yeah can I say real quick there was like
this is a great real quick there's this
guy and he got depressed because this
woman he's supposed to marry like said
she wasn't gonna marry him and he jumped
off the top of a building yeah right and
he ends up landing on the woman she goes
to the hospital and he's fine
Pence has worse timing than that woman
very very very important you may have
missed her all week but Kat will be back
next week but she'll also be returning
to her hometown of Detroit for two shows
at the Majestic Theater Saturday and
Sunday October 7th and 8th go to
realcattemp.com for Ticket info there
are tickets available it's a great show
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else